Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg will
testify before three congressional
committees next week about the companies
handling of its users information the
social media giant now says data firm
Cambridge analytic agayn unauthorized
access to information from up to 87
million people that is far more than the
50 million or so previously reported
Zuckerberg told reporters yesterday he
is still the best person to run Facebook
but he also admitted Facebook made a
huge mistake and said it can do better
to protect user data and in his words at
the end of the day this was my
responsibility Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with what Zuckerberg can
expect from lawmakers Nancy good morning
good morning well they tell us they want
to know whether any other companies have
been able to get access to this kind of
data and exactly what kind of
information we are talking about now
Zuckerberg insists that Facebook has
gotten a lot better at protecting user
information but he also admitted that
every Facebook user and there are about
two billion of them should assume that
at some point their personal information
has been scraped from the site by a
third party it's clear now that we
didn't do enough
in a rare conference call with reporters
Zuckerberg fell on his sword
acknowledging that a company hired by
the Trump campaign was able to access
the personal data of far more users than
previously believed up to 87 million
people unwittingly shared their
information with Cambridge analytic ah a
political consulting firm partially
funded by the billionaire Mercer family
when you're building something like
Facebook there are going to be things
that you messed up and if we've gotten
this right we would have messed
something else but some lawmakers see
this as the latest in a series of
security blunders that Zuckerberg should
answer for in person here needs to be
cleared by the CEO they want to know why
Zuckerberg initially laughed off the
notion of foreign meddling back in 2016
the idea that you know fake news on
Facebook influence the election in any
way I think is a pretty crazy idea
he says was a mistake that has since
been fixed
just this week Facebook removed more
than 270 Russian pages and accounts and
restricted apps from accessing certain
details about you and your friends still
Facebook's stock price has tumbled more
than 10 percent since last month Morgan
Stanley warning that data privacy issues
are feeding investor concern how can you
ever fully reassure users that their
information isn't going to be used in a
way that they don't expect we can
certainly do a better job of explaining
what we actually do the vast majority of
the data that that Facebook knows about
you is because you chose to share it
Zuckerberg was asked whether anyone at
Facebook has been fired over this
Cambridge analytical scandal and he said
no he has said however that social media
companies like Facebook perhaps should
be regulated more heavily by the federal
government and that Nora is certain to
be a big topic of conversation when he
testifies here on Capitol Hill next week
it's gonna be busy Nancy will be
watching thank you so much